hi I'm Richard Blais and today we're
making spaghetti and meatballs with bone
marinara sauce which is punny so
actually like this dish came about from
just the pun and the wordplay of the
dish but when you get down to it the
flavor of bone marrow which a lot of
people call gods butter which is a
pretty like that's an impressive title
to hang on bone marrow like wow right
like now you have to use it so adding
bone marrow just gives it this little
meaty flavor it's really soft so it just
adds a nice nuance to the tomato sauce
this recipe is something that we cook a
lot in my house so my daughter's love
spaghetti and meatballs it's one of
their favorite dishes so I cook it a lot
at home I'm a native New Yorker so like
this is what we do on Sunday nights
right you might call it Brooklyn gravy I
might call it bone marinara but it's all
the same thing and the most important
thing with spaghetti and meatballs is
the meatballs right so they have to have
a great texture so it's all about that
perfect ratio of meat to fat whether
that's pork fat or ricotta cheese or
bone marrow perhaps it's really the
texture of the meatball that's the most
important so this is just classic
comfort food the stuff that you want to
eat the stuff that you crave delicious
simple food
[Music]
all right so bone marrow you can just
ask your butcher for some or sometimes
it's called soup bones and then what do
you do when you actually get the bone
marrow is you have to scrape the marrow
from the bone so you can do that two
ways you can pop it in a hot oven for
just a couple of minutes and then you
pull it out of the oven and pop it right
out of the bone or you can just get a
paring knife or a spoon and sort of
scoop the marrow out as well bone marrow
meat tomato tomato meat bone marrow you
said to introduce it I'm sorry I'm a dad
this everyone knows I'm a dad bone
marrow of just sort of melts as the
meatballs cooking I love the camaraderie
of a kitchen that's what inspired me to
cook professionally I always play sports
and just hanging out being on a team and
that's really what cooking is all about
whether you're doing it at home with
your family or professionally in a
kitchen
the energy of a busy restaurant is
unparalleled but when you're cooking at
home just for a few people there's just
something really special about that we
cook because we just want to make people
happy and what better place to start
than doing that with your family and
friends
[Music]